jacques attali est cette semaine
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous donc
assure-t-il à ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec life fait avec les échos et
radio classique
vous êtes avec nous à un moment vous
avez décidé de quelle manière de faire
entendre votre voix dans le débat
présidentiel jacques attali et donc vous
répondrai au cours de cette émission à
trois grandes questions d'abord le
piratant les français à vous lire 1 avec
françois fillon est ce que vous n'êtes
pas dans la caricature vous répondrez à
jean francis pécresse
ensuite comment pouvez vous imaginer une
primaire allant de macron à mélenchon
vous l'a jugé possible souhaitable
marc réel de la fp vous interrogera à ce
sujet enfin que proposerait aujourd'hui
une commission attali pour la croissance
mais qu'elle a metz vous le demandera
alors que vous développez vous à vos
idées pour pour sortir de l'impasse et
vous encourager par ailleurs les acteurs
d'un monde meilleur avec la fondation
que vous présidez positive planète mais
d'abord jacques attali une question
d'actualité
[Musique]
manuel valls on l'a suivi ces derniers
jours a mis en scène sa stratégie de la
tension avec françois hollande
est ce qu'on peut parler de crise de
régime on aurait pu parler de crise de
régime civil prévu nistre avait
démissionné ou s'il s'était présenté en
essayant de rester privées unissent mais
il ne l'a pas fait donc tout ça est pour
l'instant une tempête dans un verre
d'eau quand même personne n'est dupe
quand même de cet apaisement qui a été
annoncé avec ce déjeuner en tête à tête
à l'elysée on sait que manuel valls n'a
renoncé à rien est ce que la guerre
quand même et déclaré toujours très à
droite on a connu ça aussi une bataille
entre les différents candidats possibles
à l'élection présidentielle il y aura la
même chose à gauche qui a déjà commencé
entre tous ceux qui sont candidats à
gauche à l'élection plutôt signe ça
rejoint votre question précédente
est ce qu'il y aura une primaire de
toutes les gauches et moi je peux vous
dire elle aura lieu alors là on parlera
mais là on parle quand même du duo de
l'exécutif est la plus important c'est
qu'ils se concentrent sur l'exercice de
leur métier comme premier ministre y
compris dans la pluie que c'est très
important ça a l'air aussi un obstacle
pour moi pour voir l'un ou l'autre
devenir candidat à l'élection primaire
en restant dans leur fonction parce que
l'élection primaire on l'a vu avec les
candidats de droite ça prend beaucoup de
temps avec très difficile d'être bénigne
et président ali ben ibrahim et que vous
avez entendu vous avez lu encore
dimanche bien sûr c'est une interview
qui a tout a tout accéléré
manuel valls qui envisageait de se
présenter contre françois hollande sbca
n'est pas là quand même manqué
incroyablement de loyauté non d'abord ce
qu'il le dit de façon très transparente
il pourrait très bien le faire moi je
vais pas de ne pas d'obstacle à ça ça me
paraît pas alors alors on vous écoute
tout est normal
non il signera un homme politique
la moindre des choses c'est qu'il ait
envie de devenir président république
c'est même la seule fonction vraiment
intéressante dans la république donc que
manuel valls et on devrait devenir
présente lui se paraît tout à fait sain
et en plus il le dit de façon
transparente et il n'a pas créé des
conditions d'une rupture avant le fait
avant vous êtes le premier quand même à
dix la trouvez ça normal
1 je trouverais de défier président de
la république s'est pas défier
je veux pas c'est pas défier cetc c'est
dire qu'il se met sur les rangs pour
tous ceux qui se trouvent et je vous le
dit la primaire totale aura lieu je vais
vous dire dans quelles conditions
d'accord on verra ça dans un instant
encore une question quand même sur cette
crise de régime que vous niez quand même
ça donne des arguments à la droite on
l'a encore entendu aujourd'hui dénoncé
l'incapacité des exécutifs et puis la
perte d'autorité du président se sont
effet là que vous contestez également le
président ne se mêle pas de cette
bagarre il laisse son premier ministre
et les adhésions de s'exprimer je pense
pas qu'il ya perte d'autorité plus
spécialement dans ce cas là c'est vrai
que tout le monde attend de la question
de la question de savoir s'il sera
candidat ou pas et donc ça donne un
sentiment d'incertitude mon failli
encore totalement et plein de façon
pleine et entière j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec lui aujourd'hui
président de la république il exerce ses
fonctions pleinement et la république et
tous les français qu'ils soient de
gauche ou de droite n'ont pas intérêt à
ce que le président soit affaibli
surtout il ya des menaces autour du pays
vous avez déjeuné avec lui en tête à
tête de n'être pas d'accord
confidences à vous révéler pas de
confidence mais quand même une
impression vous avez tiré une impression
de sa volonté de se présenter ou sans
tirer la conclusion que le président l'a
public est présent là public et qui fait
son métier à fond d'accord quand même on
se dit qu'une telle guerre entre les
deux têtes de l'exécutif haute et aurait
été impensable du temps de françois
mitterrand avait vous moquez de mémoire
parce qu'elle a eu lieu avec une
violence extrême
d'abord évidemment sous la cohabitation
avec jacques chirac et avec edouard
balladur puis avec michel rocard s'était
pas tendre du tout c'était même extrême
beaucoup plus dur que ça ne l'est
aujourd'hui
oui mais c'était dur de la part du chef
de l'état à l'encontre du premier
ministre à celle inverse un rat monsieur
doit ça ça indique quand même ce n'est
pas tout à fait nouveau et on peut
retrouver d'autres traces il ya eu aussi
sous giscard d'estaing avec chirac qui
était d'une extrême violence
d'accord bon on attend maintenant la
décision du chef de l'état vous avez
déjeuné à sa table aujourd'hui jacques
attali si nous étions donc il s'est
amusé comme ça à jouer avec les nerfs de
tout le monde nous cette confidence
particulier à faire le jeu
je suis pour ma part convaincu que ce
psychodrame passé c'est un moment ou un
autre
d'une façon ou d'une autre je n'ai pas
la réponse je ne connais pas une mais
n'a pas fait cette confiance mais je
crois que le plus important aujourd'hui
c'est que en tant que d'emblée fasse son
métier pas une république et que le
candidat six candidats il ya s'exprime
le plus tard possible le plus tard
possible c'est mon point de vue bon
d'accord il nous a pas fait de
confidences mais peut-être que vous vous
lui avez dispenser un conseil ou
plusieurs jeux vous êtes arrivée les
jeunes est mis sur la place publique
j'ai dit ce qui me paraissait nécessaire
c'est que le présent la pluie ne soit
pas candidat à la primaire du parti
socialiste primaires qu'il peut désigner
que le perdant puisque cette primaire
est étroite donc au mur à d'autres
candidats désignés que le perdant que
s'il veut être candidat il faut être
candidat à herbie à torby c'est à dire
en tant que président la pluie qui
ornent la primaire et c'est son droit et
qu' ils fassent l'impossible pour faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une primaire avant
le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de tous les candidats
sinon cette primaire aura lieu quoi
qu'il arrive parce que la primaire de la
gauche sera le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle qui désignera
le meilleur camp de la gauche mais ça
sera complètement idiot parce que le
meilleur candidat de la gauche sera
forcément troisième les clubs
présidentielle est une gagnante dont
l'absurdité de refuser une primaire de
toutes les gauches c'est d'assumer que
la première de toutes les gauches et la
primaire perdante du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle ok on
reparlera de la primaire et de vos
propositions dans un instant mais
d'abord c'est jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique que l'on accueille pour la
première partie de l'émission
voir en français bonsoir michel bonsoir
jacques attali alors dans une tribune
publiée hier dans le monde vous écrivez
que en substance si françois fillon
était élu président de la république les
français auraient droit à travailler
plus à plus de précarité et à plus
d'impôts est ce que c'est pas un tout
petit peu caricatural on ne vous
reconnais pas dans ce jugement un peu à
l'emporte-pièce d'abord j'ai paniqué
contre travailler plus c'est vers plus
de flexibilité c'est nécessaire et
travailler plus longtemps pour autant
des retraites c'est nécessaire c'était
contre doivent pas à mon raisonnement
est plutôt de dire puisque je m'adresse
à la gauche dans cet article je lis et
je reviendrai sur le programme de
françois fillon jeudi
si voulant de gauche vous pensez
vraiment que c'est cataclysmique ce qui
pourrait avec fillon a créé les
conditions pour le battre ne vous
occupez pas que de vous même mais créer
les conditions pour pouvoir le battre
donc vous vous êtes pas cohérent si vous
dites à la fois c'est épouvantable ce
qui nous attend et françois fillon et si
vous créez pas les conditions pour le
battre parce que maintenant revenue au
programme de temps votre rapport que
vous aviez publié en 2008 le rapport
pour la libération de la croissance
française vous préconisiez déjà un
certain nombre de choses que préconise
france absolument et je le veux je suis
entièrement d'accord avec un grand
nombre de propositions de françois
fillon je suis entièrement d'accord avec
un grand nombre de propositions de
françois fillon en particulier ce qu'il
dit sur la russie ce qui est du scion
l'évolution du travail et beaucoup de
choses sur lesquelles je suis pas
d'accord la réforme de l'école je la
vois pas comme ça à la réforme de la
fonction publique la vois pas comme ça
mais enfin je suis d'accord sur
certaines dimensions de ces d'autant
plus amusant s'il faut rappeler ce
souvenir c'est que la commission que
m'avait demandé de présider nicolas sûr
que j'y suis pas nicolas sarkozy qui me
l'a demandé si c'est françois fillon
françois fillon m'a appelé pour me
demander de présider cette commission et
je les fais avec
en lui disant je le fais un grand
plaisir si c'est une commission
bipartisane
ensuite nicolas sarkozy a cosigné la
lettre de mission que m'a demandé un
françois fillon qui avait eu l'idée et
j'ai merveilleusement travaillé avec
françois fillon dans l'exercice de ce
rapport dans sa préparation j'ai tous
les moyens pour travailler ça s'est très
bien passé
et pendant les cinq ans où il a été
premier ministre je venais le voir très
souvent il m'appelait très souvent
voir dans quelles conditions ce rapport
pouvait être mise en oeuvre et j'ai
toujours eu le sentiment senti avec lui
et avec le président que c'était le
président qui l'empêché de mettre en
oeuvre le rapport n'est que lui-même me
disait très souvent ah si je pouvais je
ferai tout tout de suite je ne sais pas
s'il l'aurait fait mais en tout cas j'ai
senti quelqu'un qui avait véritablement
la hutte fait au point même que je le
dis à plusieurs reprises vous devriez me
lasser de démissionner c'est la seule
façon pour abreuver nice d'exercer ses
responsabilités alors précisément qu'est
ce qui vous plaît dans son projet
présidentiel
d'abord je sais que j'aime le courage
j'aime la méthode d'agir vite j'ai fait
moi-même un programme présidentiel qui
est paru il ya quelques mois et on peut
comparer ce qui est commun et ce qui ne
l'est pas j'aime la méthode d'agir vite
tout de suite de faire tout très vite
j'aime le fait de proposer de créer les
conditions de d'égaliser les conditions
de la retraite de tous les français
d'augmenter la tva plutôt que les impôts
directs de réduire les charges de
réduire l'impôt sur les sociétés tout ça
me c'est exactement ce qu'il ya dans le
programme que j'ai présenté moi mais
c'est pour ça que j'avais un peu étonné
de vous voir prendre position contre
l'augmentation d'impôts parce qu'il ya
pas véritablement dans le programme
précis de la fille en dehors de la tva
d'augmentation en effet j'ai pourquoi
j'ai dit tout haut des baisses d'impôts
s'est dit plutôt si vous vous jure de
gauche vous êtes dans ce disque au alors
créer les conditions de la cave vous y
opposer sur ce point je suppose suis
même aussi assez favorable très
favorable je pense que je le dis depuis
très longtemps c'est pas lui qui m'a
convaincu à une autre attitude à l'égard
de la russie
pour moi ce fait trente ans que je
considère que cela aussi fait partie de
l'europe
c'est une absurdité de l'avoir isolé une
grande erreur de la politique de
étrangères de l'actuel président est son
ancien diocèse d'angers que d'avoir
participé à l' isolement de la russie ce
moment c'est vrai et donc je pense en
effet que nos adversaires principaux
sont à mossoul et pas moscou ni la
menace qui est un adversaire
épouvantable qui n'est pas le premier
d'entre eux que de ce point de vue je
suis d'accord avec lui je suis
évidemment pas d'accord du tout avec lui
sur toutes les questions de moeurs sur
la remise en cause de la loi taubira je
suis pas d'accord sur l'entrée
subreptice du fait religieux dans la
république qui me paraît extrêmement
dangereux parce que si on discours
public en tout terrain et ici aussi on
look sur l'autorisent aux catholiques
pourquoi le refuser aux musulmans et ça
créera et aux autres régions ça ouvre
une boîte de pandore extrêmement
dangereuse
vous avez vous avez voté à la primaire
de la droite non vous auriez pu voter
fillon j'aurais j'aurais pu pousser
c'est très compliqué les gens de gauche
puisque je suis de gauche
les gens de gauche ont pu voter pour
fillon pour battre sarkozy ce qu'ils ont
fait puis ensuite juppé pour battre
fillon ou voter pour fillon je connais
dans les deux cas qui ont été soit jp
pour battre lyon ou fillon parce qu'ils
pensent que c'est le meilleur adversaire
possible pour la gauche
est ce que vous ne craignez pas quand
même que un rapprochement avec vladimir
poutine pourrait se faire au détriment
de l'europe et c'est ce que craignent
notamment nos partenaires allemands
alors d'abord je suis pour continuer les
compliments j'aime beaucoup le discours
de françois fillon sur l'europe et en
particulier sur n'a essayé de renforcer
l'intégration avec l'allemagne la
coopération sur trois points qu'ils
proposent c'est tout à fait des choses
que moi j'ai proposé depuis longtemps et
donc je me suis d'abord n'a pas beaucoup
parlé on n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais si
je peux paraître c'est un peu avancé des
bars et un peu aussi la faute des souris
l'interroger puisque ils n'ont pas
dérogé ni sur le climat n'est sur la
révolution numérique n'y a ni sur
l'europe
l'étrange lacunes mais le pour moi et
c'est un sujet philosophique très
important pour moi la russie est en
europe
il ne faut absolument pas faire la même
erreur avec la russie qu'on a fait avec
la turquie la turquie on l'a isolé est
bon a dit et ça a donné ce que ça donne
c'est à dire une dictature épouvantable
qui évidemment n'est plus en europe qui
a choisi si on fait la même chose avec
la russie on aura la même résultat donc
la russie pour moi est en europe
d'ailleurs surprenait discours de
poutine à son arrivée au pouvoir il
avait même laissé entendre qu'il voulait
rejoindre l'union européenne
et pour moi la littérature russe la
musique russes montrent que la russie
est une nation européenne
donc il faut pas opposer la russie
l'europe et vers l'allemagne est tout à
fait sur cette ligne et je pense qu'on a
une nouvelle perspective intéressante
est ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à parler
avec assad
non je pense qu'il faut considérer que
notre ennemi premier est à mossoul et
que notre ennemi seconde état et à damas
mais il faut pas parler avec assad
j'étais à beyrouth la semaine dernière
pour positif planète pour voir tout ce
qui se passe avec la tragédie des
réfugiés je veux dire ne pas rouvrir une
ambassade un pardon non rouvrir une
ambassade rouvrir une ambassade
maintenant d'abord les conditions ne
sont pas réunies de sécurité sont pas
réunies et d'autres nous avons à la base
leur mais qui n'est pas à damas
on va revenir aux propositions
économiques et sociales de françois
fillon je vous propose de l'écouter
si hier soir il a affirmé ce qu'il
disait d'ailleurs durant sa campagne
qu'il ne pleuvra amender son projet et
il a donc ne rien faire mais qu'il ne
bougerait pas en lait coûte suis pas
candidat pour m'asseoir dans un fauteuil
à l'elysée attendre que le temps passe
je suis candidat pour redresser mon pays
j'ai la conviction que le seul projet
qui permet de redresser
mon pays c'est un projet qui grosso modo
peut se résumer de la manière suivante
il faut qu'on travaille un petit peu
plus parce qu'on travaille moins tous
les autres européens
il faut qu'on dépense un peu moins
d'argent public puisqu'on n'en dépense
plus que tous les autres européens
donc c'est autour de ce projet là que je
vais continuer d'avancer
alors je crois que c'est pas tout à fait
exact de dire qu'on travaille plus que
moi que les autres gens bien les
statistiques se discute on se raconte
par ailleurs pas pareil
deuxièmement je crois qu'il ya un débat
qui aurait commencé à ouvrir un peu de
gens ouverts c'est que c'est la question
des élections législatives parce que le
président lui n'a aucun pouvoir sur les
sujets dont il vient de parler c'est le
parlement qui en décide et donc il est
très important de savoir s'il va avoir
une majorité et avoir une majorité sont
négociés avec des partenariats l'accueil
qu'il a fait dans l'histoire récente
c'est françois mitterrand 1981 quand il
avait une majorité écrasante pour un
programme décidé à l'avancé qu'on a pu
et qui existait en trois voies après
plus personne n'a eu cette majorité il a
fallu négocier tôt je pense que le futur
président un public qui qu'il soit il
aura une majorité aura besoin de
négocier avec ses partenaires
est-ce que cinq cent mille postes de
fonctionnaires en moins dans les cinq
années est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui possible pas parce que vous savez
que c'est le grand débat de savoir si
c'est réaliste ou pas d'abord ces cinq
cent mille comptant les collectivités
locales absolument d'eau donc c'est
impossible sans réformer la constitution
parce que la constitution
dans l'état actuel ne permet pas repris
leur appliquer un état au général de
toucher aux personnels des collectivités
locales qui peuvent augmenter les impôts
comme ils veulent donc ce 500000 n'a pas
de sens puisque il compte deux cent
cinquante mille de collectivités locales
sur lequel l'état n'aura aucun pouvoir
premièrement
deuxièmement il ya des tas de secteurs
où il faut augmenter le nombre de
personnel en particulier dans
l'éducation et dans la santé et dans la
police et dans l'armée
donc si vous augmentez ça ou vous les
enlevez moi je pense que les vrais
progrès seront offertes par le numérique
progressivement mais on veut pas
aujourd'hui dans l'état actuel des
besoins sécurité en défense en santé et
en éducation parler d'une telle
réduction du personnel sur sauf les
collectifs sur l'édification d'un patois
voilà justement est-ce que vous avez vu
aujourd'hui paraître une étude très
important et à ce trafic catastrophique
pour le niveau des écoliers français en
maths et en sciences
pour faire clair on est derniers ont
garni de l'union européenne sait on est
très très mal classés dans les 50 pays
de là encore dense dans le rapport quoi
dans la proposition prévenu pour la
présidentielle que j'avais fait howell
avril sous le nom de france 2022 visant
à ce qu'on pourrait obtenir entre eux
j'avais insisté comme preuve nous avions
c'est un gros collectif insisté sur
comme premier réforme qui n'est pas
repris par françois fillon la réforme de
l'école maternelle pour donner davantage
de boyer à l'école maternelle dans les
quartiers défavorisés nous sommes en
effet une question de moyens si j'ai
bien regardé l'étude
parce que le nombre d'heures des
écoliers français est supérieur à celui
de leurs voisins parfois un sens qu'une
question de pour moi tout se joue et les
études sur montrer celles de l'osce et
du pisa celle de de l'institut montaigne
tous les rapports montrent que tout se
joue à l'école maternelle et qu' un
petit nombre de jeunes français arrivent
en primaire en parlant 1500 beau et que
un bon tiers sinon plus arrivent en
parlant 300 mots c'est fini c'est réglé
et c'est là où se pose le problème
donc il faut renforcer l'encadrement
dans ces quartiers défavorisés pour
créer mais on a beaucoup de mal à le
faire parce qu'on ne trouve pas de prof
de maths en particulier de maths
d'ailleurs absolument
est-ce qu'on parce qu'on les paye mal
ils vont vers d'autres métiers
ingénieurs notamment qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait ferry ce que j'avais dit la
solution c'est de revaloriser les salles
et même une jeune enseignante ses
semblables
en effet beaucoup de professeurs ils ont
mal payés sont les méthodes pédagogiques
sont à mettre en cause aussi peut-être
tonnes pédagogiques sont à mettre en
cause il ya aussi il ya aussi d'aider
des expériences qu'on n'arrive pas à
généraliser en france qui sont faits par
différents enseignants on sait très bien
ce qu'il faudrait faire donc c'est pas
le généraliser c'est très difficile de
changer cette machine mais c'est vrai
que mettre l'accent sur l'école
maternelle qui n'aura d'impact dans dix
ans et c'est pour ça qu'on le fait pas
parce qu'on veut des résultats tout de
suite on n'aurait jamais dû faire la
réforme des rythmes scolaires qui était
pas une priorité ni la forme du collège
qui est pas une priorité il faut prendre
les choses en amont 6 à 20 ans on avait
touché aux maternelles on n'en serait
pas là aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
retenez de bons du quinquennat de
françois hollande
je retiens de bon la gestion de la
politique de défense nous paraît
vraiment très remarquable
je trouve que je retiens de bon là sa
réforme progressive d'information
permanent de même si elle me paraît très
insuffisante c'est la formation des
chômeurs qui me paraît une bonne chose
beaucoup de choses sur les moeurs la loi
sur le mariage pour tous me paraît une
avancée sociale
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas mais qui
maintenant est entrée en vigueur dans à
peu près tous les pays du monde
développé qui doit rester là voilà je
crois que j'ai dit l'essentiel
dernière question castro fidel castro
pour vous c'est un tyran ou un héros se
tirant bien sûr ce d'épouvantables tir
en jetant un tyran domestique est un
tyran j'ai rencontré donc humainement il
était fascinant mais ça n'empêche c'est
un horrible dictateur alors comme
romancier je le trouve fascinant mais
comme en politique dans l'épouvantable
qui ont soigné la barre des 1 1 c'est à
ses obsèques
ce qu'il faut dire que la france envoie
ségolène royal août est vrai je ne le
pense pas vous ne pensez pas non je
pense pas qu'il faut être présent aux
obsèques d'un dictateur qui a massacré
massacrer son peuple
par contre je pense que les américains
ont aggravé la situation qui n'était
déjà pas attendre en l'isolant et que la
meilleure solution c'est celle qu'on
employait à l'égard de l'espagne de
franco
dans lequel on a noyé la dictature
espagnole sous les touristes et le
système s'est effondré comme un sucre
fond dans l'eau voilà merci merci je
retiens de cette première partie jacques
attali que vous
considérez pas comme arnaud montebourg
que ce que propose fillon ce serait une
politique de la terre brûlée fans
chériennes 1
vous êtes beaucoup plus mesurée voilà
vous savez je suis pas manichéen et je
suivais chez c'est raymond aron qui
disait être de gauche ou de droite c'est
être hémiplégique
voilà merci encore enfin si ce deuxième
partie de l'épreuve de vérité maintenant
avec marc presles de la sp qui nous
rejoint pour parler justement de la
primaire de gauche il est prof de vérité
avec la fp
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur attali alors on
a vous en avez parlé vous en propose le
proposer aujourd'hui dans le monde dans
le journal le monde vous en avait parlé
à quelques instants sur ce plateau
vous imaginez en fait une primaire qui
rassemble de mélenchon à maquereau
comment vous pouvez imaginer une seule
seconde que ce qui a été refusé depuis
des semaines
clairement par ces candidats peu puisse
encore se passer
d'abord il faut que l'opinion publique
prennent conscience que cette primaire
tout à l'air aura lieu parce que le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est une primaire de la
gauche
accessoirement puisqu'ils seront tous là
et alors un qui sera évidemment mieux
classé que les autres donc la première
de la gauche même s'ils veulent éviter l
aura lieu à ce moment là
naturellement ça ne désignera un
troisième parce que à une peine et on
soit fier au second avant c'est
complètement idiot si cette primaire qui
aura lieu de toute façon avait lieu
avant dans ce cas là eh bien elle
dessine à quelqu'un qui pourrait avoir
une chance d'être devant marine le pen
et donc on aurait plus gros tours
monsieur x contre monsieur fillon ce qui
serait quand même plus conforme à l'idée
que je me fais de la france dont c'est
la seule chance de la gauche d'être au
2e c'est la seule chance de la gauche
attendu à lorsque les candidats en
question en tête c'est je vais avancer
tout seul et au mois de février je fais
exploser les autres parce que les
sondages vont mettre en tête et personne
n'osera résister à cette question si
vous restez vous tuer la gauche donc je
fais campagne où seul en février
monsieur mélenchon monsieur montebourg
monsieur filoche monsieur macro pense
qu'ils seront 15 % des voix et que les
autres 5 et que les autres objets de sa
peut pas se produire c'est suicidaire
s'il ne croit vraiment ils ont conféré
de primaire mais il ya déjà des sondages
qui donnent des indications précieuses
aujourd'hui sur les avantages des uns et
des autres avec des candidats qui se
détache notamment on voit là et un
sondage aujourd'hui qui donne macron à
17% le président de république est très
loin 8%
est ce que justement je leur ai dit pas
ce scénario désir tient peut-être un des
candidats va se détacher les autres
renom seront de fait je crois pas qu'ils
renonceront je crois que le prix blue
parti sioniste pas renoncé à voir son
candidat si les gens que l'on se serait
suicidé a pour tout le monde
renoncera pas il ne peut renoncer que
s'il ya une primaire de gauche il
désigna grandiose à gauche et lorsque la
la famille rassemblée à désigner à
conduire mais si on va au bout ils
resteront je voulais revenir sur quelque
chose que vous avez expliqué comment
s'expliquer tout à l'heure c'est que
vous dites
certes on vous suit il faut rassembler
la gauche pour être premier tour mais là
vous dites la primaire socialiste qui se
dessine avec françois hollande arnaud
montebourg benoît hamon
finalement il ya plus besoin de la faire
pourquoi moi je conseille pas logique a
plus besoin de le faire puisqu'il faut
une primaire d'ensemble mais si cette
primaire là ne se fait pas à cette
primaire d'ensemble qui probablement ne
se fera pas n'a pas lieu
- puisque françois hollande voire
renoncer à la primaire du ps oui mon
conseil personnel je ne dis pas que tu
as suivi ce qui lie pas la primaire
parce que cette primaire trois
inconvénients pour le président un
public et pour le pays parce que le pays
bas thérèse plus que pour les
républiques premier inconvénient le
président république sera prix pourra
pas faire son boulot de président un
public parce qu'il sera pris par des
meetings de partout à une primaire
deuxièmement cette primaire c'est du
quinquennat et on peut terminer comme
maintenant j'attends des normes de
travail il se passe énormément de choses
et la situation exige un homme à la
manette aux manettes c'est plaisant de
la public deuxième conseil conclusion
c'est complètement idiot de faire une
campagne pour une primaire qui va
désigner un perdant aucun sens c'est
vraiment du du town tu t'en bienvenus et
troisièmement un show que la fonction
présidentielle
le impose d'être soit le candidat toute
une famille large assemblée soit
candidat tout seul donc moi je lui
conseillerais net je ne je ne dis pas
qu'il le fera et j'ai pas de davie parts
de gfa et de confidences particulier je
considérais de ne pas être candidat à
cette primaire d'être candidat s'ils le
souhaitent je ne sais pas s'il y sera
d'être candidat on devra en tant que
président de la république tel discours
qu'on entend là ses dernières gravats là
vous n'êtes pas le seul à des résidents
qui ont qui ont aujourd'hui je me suis
pas concertés avec personne
j'ai en effet déjeuner avec a priori
plus qu'on a parlé tout à fait autre
chose n'a pas parlé de ça une seconde et
c'est ce que je disais dans l'article
l'espace hier à lui à 2
du monde hier je ne lui conseille pas
d'être candidat comme je conseille aux
autres mélenchon et macro et emmanuel
est un ami très proche je suis très fier
d'avoir été à l'origine et revient de sa
carrière et c'est un très intéressant et
je suis convaincu qu'il sera un jour
pression de la rue mais je suis
convaincu qu est le sera un jour s'il
sylla la persistance de deux d'accepter
les défaites d'apprendre je suis
convaincu qu'il le sera un jour on va
lui demander d'être patient je ne mens
pas je lui dis je le sais déjà parce que
nous en avons souvent parlé je pense que
il espère être président c'est possible
mais je pense qu'il construit une vraie
carrière et que c'est très courageux de
sa part d'avoir alors qu'il aurait pu
faire tout à fait autre chose d'avoir
accepté de participer à la vie
démocratique on va l'écouter on va
écouter également jean-luc mélenchon
donc tout oppose sauf le refus de la
primaire je te crois que vous vous
prenez jacques attali mais donc chacun a
choisi son cheminement personnel on les
écoute moi je propose ma candidature
c'est le peuple qui va en disposer je me
demande la permission à personne je le
fais hors cadre de parti je suis ouvert
à tout le monde
les organisations les réseaux mais les
citoyens d'abord depuis six mois
tous les sondages montrent que la gauche
n'existe pas au second tour
je n'ai jamais été testée comme un
candidat de gauche mais comme un
candidat de rassemblement ce qui est mon
projet et ce rassemblement progressiste
et celui auquel je crois et que en effet
je suis aujourd'hui on est 100 d'âge au
dessus des candidats de la gauche mais
je pense que la gauche n'a pas besoin de
moi pour perdre oui il sape dit le
contraire puisqu'il a aussi dit qu'il
était un homme de gauche donc faut
clarifier le discours là la vraie chance
pour avoir un candidat de la gauche
parce que maintenant le maquereau peut
plus dire ce qu'il veut mais où il est
candidate à gauche oui les grandeurs
nulle part est nulle part c'est pas je
pense pas peut-être que je me trompe
mais je pense pas qu'un conte cas de nul
part puisse gagner l'élection
présidentielle mais après tout mais je
crains pas gagné on est entendu par donc
c'est pas exclu juste sur les 40 et je
pense que le plus de ce qui peut changer
c'est que un grande manifestation du
pays et des gens de gauche demande exige
il prévient du thé gauche j'ai lancé moi
même
une pétition sur change.org il ya déjà
presque 1000 personnes quelques heures
qui ont signé pour que les français
demandent cette primaire de gauche et on
peut même rêver dans la rue par internet
c'est plus simple j'ai rigolé un peu
plus discret mais on peut même aussi
rêver de l'organiser cette primaire sans
les candidats d'organiser une primaire
sans que les candidats le soir souligné
leur absence pour souligner la ram
choses et faire cette primaire je
voulais juste citoyenne où les citoyens
décident de voter pour les caunois vous
êtes crier ça y est vous mettez les
mains dans le cambouis ladauge je
l'imaginé je dis pas que j'ai imaginé
faire juste pour revenir sur le décalage
entre jean luc mélenchon sur ce spectre
en fait qui va de gens les financements
emmanuel macron vous écrivez aujourd'hui
dans le monde qu' il n'y a pas deux il
ya les mêmes il n'y a pas autant de
différence entre jean françois poisson
jean frédéric poisson pardon et de la
haine entre m et jean luc mélenchon et
même macron vous exagérez
ah non je crois pas je crois pas je
crois vraiment que les différences sont
sont aussi grandes jean françois pons
poisson c'est jean frédéric poisson
c'est les extrêmes qu'il est nathalie
kosciusko c'est le hasard de la vie qui
n'a bien droite elle aurait pu être à
gauche comme emmanuel macron un peu à
droite
il est venu à gauche par ce même
beaucoup de choses communes dans les
programmes de droite même si avide et dr
oui mais il ya aussi beaucoup de choses
communes entre les idées de caisse qui a
justement dans les idées de jean luc
mélenchon emmanuel macron serait qu'on a
envie de vous entendre il ya le refus
des injustices qui me paraît fondamental
chez eux comme un vrai mot commun il ya
la passion pour l'europe parce qu'on
oublie que jean luc mélenchon et
pro-européen j'ai souvent débattu avec
lui fait quelquefois les battues avec
lui les pro européens et pour l'euro
donc ça c'est quand même un point commun
et c'est des points
lutter contre les inégalités et
renforcer la zone euro
c'est quand même des des poids
fondamentaux autour duquel s'articulent
beaucoup de choses communes
je jouais revenir sur la juste derrière
questions sur la primaire qui était
cette primaire elle a été conçue à
gauche par le parti socialiste par jean
christophe cambadélis pour servir de
tremplin à françois hollande qui était
décrédibiliser de dire voilà il va paris
va gagner un premier round et ça va le
relancer pour la campagne aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il est en situation difficile il
ya des sondages qui le donnent à touche
touche avec arnaud mans
bourg est ce qu'aujourd'hui le fait de
renoncer à cette primaire on va dire
socialiste puisque de fait il n'y a plus
que le ps c'est pas une façon de reculer
en disant ah bah je peut la perdre je
n'y vais pas vous soyez pas amnésiques
les sondages hommes de monsieur trup les
sondages du break si tous les ouvrages
de monsieur fillon conduisent à ce qu'
on est plus mauvais sondages à voir les
plus grands experts nous sommes c'est
pas gagné personne aujourd'hui on peut
dire c'est gagner à 100 % pour françois
hollande et son âge sont une source
d'espérance
les hommes politiques parce que votre
proposition n'arrive pas trop tard
aujourd'hui on al impression qu
effectivement votre idée ne pourra
jamais oh oui où il peut être trop tôt
il sait gothard non peut-être trop tôt
il vous assez tôt pour que le moi je
crois beaucoup que l'opinion publique
veut leur imposer la bataille des ego et
un suicide pour la gauche la bataille
des ego et un suicide pour la gauche
et si ensuite monsieur fillon
l'emportent et que la gauche proteste
contre la politique à elle qu'il mène on
pourra très facilement leur dire c'est
votre faute si vous vous aviez créé les
conditions d'une 20 primaires ce ne
serait pas arrivé
la gauche portera la responsabilité des
reproches qu'elle fera au président de
la république de droite c'est
entièrement de sa faute
donc ça c'est quand même un argument
très lourd on parlait de manière des
manuels macron ça a été votre
collaborateur on pouvait lire sur
françois hollande dans la vue et est ce
que c ronaldo pour lui vous avez été il
a été mon collaborateur dans une
commission initié par françois fillon
royalement des minuscules
qu'est ce que je peux dire de n'en
voulait dire de lui je vous dis c'est un
garçon remarquable très intelligent
plein de promesses j'ai dit à la fois
des choses favorables et les choses
dures sur lui que je lui ai d'ailleurs
toujours bien arrivé je crois que je
persiste à penser qu'il faut un
programme pour être candidat
présidentiel un programme clivant il dit
ce qu'il veut il pas jeter au milieu
j'ai eu droit aujourd'hui démarre on
passait encore incertain moi je n'ai pas
encore lu son livre je pense qu'il ya
des choses dedans qui précise les choses
mais pour l'instant je ne vois pas un
programme et à prendre forcément ça vous
fait des ennemis des gens qui sont pas
d'accord mais les gens qui sont d'accord
faut qu'on se bat pour quelque chose
la fondation positive planète nous
travaillons dans l'intérêt des
générations suivantes
après
pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
dans l'intérêt de cette seule fonction
qu'est ce que je fais pour le pays dont
pour les gens changent et évoluent
emmanuel mal qu'on est le seul de tous
les hommes politiques aujourd'hui qui
sera là dans 30 ans vraisemblablement
est au plus haut si on veut
vraisemblablement il peut l'être en tout
cas donc il est mieux placé que les
autres pour parler au nom de ce que sera
la france en 2040
j'aimerais qu'ils le fassent c'est quoi
la france de 2040 ou je voudrais qu'elle
aille qu'est ce que je fais pour ça et
qu'ils proposent des choses ambitieuse
et c'est ça ou d'avis que j'attends de
lui voir lisier qui il était il l'a dit
lui-même qu'il n'est ni à gauche ni à
droite etc starry skies a pas un espace
au centre pour lui notamment après la
défaite d'alain juppé je la france est
ainsi fait qu'il ya pas ce genre d'
espace quatre centres en france
le centre françois mitterrand disait je
vais formule qu'il m'invite encore vrai
le centre regarder au fond de la classe
à droite
donc je je je ne crois pas mais
peut-être va-t-il me faire mentir par
son succès faut pas exclure parce qu'il
ya d'autres arguments qui me fait penser
qu'il a des chances y compris dans une
dans une stratégie du vide du néant
programmatique c'est que les français
rêvent de se débarrasser de leur classe
politique
ils veulent plus de ces gens là donc on
peut pas dire que françois fillon soit
nouveau et on peut dire que marine le
pen qui a hérité de son père soit
nouveau donc
la chance des manuels macro c'est
d'incarner le nouveau et donc il peut
jouer une stratégie de communication qui
est de dire je suis nouveau jeu pas
besoin de programmes
mon seul programme c'est que je suis
nouveau j'ai pas de casseroles j'ai pas
d'héritage pas de passer ça peut marcher
je serais déçu pour mon pays que ça
marche parce que ça voudrait dire que
que l'image suffit à définir un projet
j'aimerais que ça non pas que ce soit
vrai seul pas dire que je souhaite pas
que emmanuelle wacongne je souhaite
qu'ils gagnent plus tard plus talons pas
forcément avec un programme avant 30 ans
non pas du tout je si si si nous
apprenons dans 10 minutes qu'il a un
programme très ambitieux je le
soutiendrai quand on est on a parlé du
front national on a vu depuis la
victoire de françois fillon que le fn
avait décidé de dax eon
à hirson sa riposte contre françois
fillon sur le côté la défense du modèle
social face à un candidat libéral qui
veut réformer et c est ce que vous ne
craignez pas dire que que qu'elle
incarne finalement oui oui judicieuse
que la défense du modèle social vous
avez eu la journée il a cité un article
dans le monde sait ce que je dis
aujourd'hui dans le bérézina de la
gauche
marine le pen incarne l'idée qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs chez aussi chez
mélenchon
naturellement je suis né qu'on partage
avec la république démocrates mais qui
est je vous protège de tout vous protège
des étrangers je vous protège des
terroristes ou voter hd là aujourd'hui
elle dit je veux protège le modèle
social attaqué françois fillon route
alors oui mais je voudrais c'est
normalement c'est à la gauche
marine le pen dit d'ailleurs et son père
l'a dit même avec cet incroyable superbe
et et cynisme qu'ils et elles je crois
le dernier parti de gauche en france le
front national ça rappelle des souvenirs
le national socialisme
donc je pense en effet que elle peut
ramasser cette mise là la classe
ouvrière peut très bien votez françois
fillon a le courage d'être impopulaire
ce qui pour moi est une qualité un homme
d'état c'est quelqu'un qui a le courage
de provisoirement impopulaire c'est un
courage mais il n'a pas cherché
attendait mais si vous cherchez
si vous cherchiez vous vous opposez aux
fonctionnaires aux retraités et
à ceux qui payent des impôts petit impôt
parce qu'ils payent la tva
ça fait du monde et donc celui qui va
dire aux jeux j'évite tout ça même si
c'est absurde c'est pas possible parce
que nous avons des dettes il faut les
réduire
que les taux d'intérêt remontent et que
le prix de la dette va augmenter eh bien
ça peut attirer des sirènes
assez assez nous vous conseilleriez à
françois fillon
justement d'élargir sa base électorale
par rapport à celles qu'il a apportées
en tête de la primaire de la droite et
ce qu'il peut le faire avec le programme
qu'il a un la france périphérique comme
on dit tout ce qu'il pense qu'il va le
faire une étable immense terre qui va
inévitablement donner ce qu'il connaît
bien la france il est né député depuis
longtemps s'intéresser aux plus faibles
mais je crois qu'il le fera déjà
atténuer certaines mesures entre ce
matin le centre et toutes ces mesures
anecdotique qui ne révèle pas du niveau
de l'élève pas du niveau départ étant un
public ce qui compte c'est de donner une
image d'empathie d'intérêt de
préoccupation pour les plus pauvres
c'est pas sur une mesure sur le
remboursement du teil quelque chose que
ce jour à la présidentielle je ne pense
pas merci marc dernière partie des
preuves de vérité maintenant avec
mickaël zeze de public sénat qui nous
rejoint
sur michael 11 ans michel vous somme
soit à vie alors une commission attali
aujourd'hui elle proposerait quoi pour
libérer la croissance
ça existe dans mon livre collectif qui
s'appelle pour que la france résiste
sans enjeu pour la france réussit ce que
j'ai publié au mois de mai dernier où
l'on propose un programme et jean
reprend l'essentiel dans ce livre
vivement après demain on essaie de
tracer le ce que sera le monde en 15 ans
et de donner quelques réformes majeures
je crois que il ya beaucoup de choses la
priorité majeure c'est donc de s'occuper
des générations suivantes la première
réforme c'est celle de l'école
maternelle dont je parlais tout à
l'heure néo deuxième porte sur la
sécurité et la sécurité le renforcement
des moyens de la police de la justice et
que dis je donne dix mesures dans sa fin
de ce livre majeur qui me paraissent du
niveau présidentiel
et ça ça permettra de relancer la
croissance entre autres c'est pas
seulement la croissance où il faut
relancer la croissance
vous savez je suis convaincu que la
france peut et doit être la première
puissance de l'europe au 21e siècle où
il n'y a pas de problème pas de panneau
by lui ça passe forcément pas parce
qu'on ne parle que de ça de cette
croissance ça ne passe que par ça oui
enfin ça passe par une croissance
différente parce que la croissance est
la condition de l'emploi mais la compte
la croissance pas dire la croissance qui
gaspille consomme la croissance peut se
faire par le recyclage le recyclage des
déchets va être un des livres absolument
essentiel de l'avenir l'économie de
croissance peut-être une économie
durable ce que moi j'appelle une
économie positive c'est à dire une
économie qui pense à protéger l'avenir
vous avez vu jacques attali tous les
mois on regarde à la loupe le le fifo à
la virgule près à 23 24 25
elle ne dépassera plus jamais cette
courbe aujourd'hui la croissance ont dit
que ça ne dépassera plus 1,5
ce quand on regarde l'europe en tout cas
tu regardes à l'échelle mondiale il ya
beaucoup d'énigmes sur cette question et
beaucoup de théories en particulier le
certains grands économistes américains
ont fait une théorie de la stagnation
séculaire qui devrait nous emporter moi
je crois pas je crois au contraire qu
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la veille de
la reprise forte d'une vague de
croissance qui lie au premier technique
est incroyable immense une puissance
énorme qui est un tsunami qui va nous
emporter mais ô combien de temps parce
qu' est-ce qu'il ya urgence de flic dans
ce livre dans les quinze ans à condition
qu'on en soit pour profiter de cette
vase il faut sans cette vague il faut se
former
quinze ans quinze ans ça veut dire que
ces quinze ans de purgatoire qui nous
attend jusqu'au nom la formation n'ont
qu'un jean de meilleur partage des
richesses 15 ans de libération des
énergies de création d'entreprise
innovation ne faire revenir les talents
moi je suis très inquiet siens points
négatifs de la france aujourd'hui
d'un poids aussi négative du
mandat de nicolas sarkozy et de françois
hollande c'est le départ des élites des
élites d'entreprise j'aime pas trop le
moule est ce son et par des
entrepreneurs c'est une erreur c'est de
leur faute c'est ça que vous êtes nos
noces et oui c'est la faute de
politiques les deux tous les deux la
passion auteurs ces personnes n'a pas su
les retenir
on n'a pas su à attirer assez
d'étrangers même s'il puis quelques
temps on crée beaucoup de startups en
france mais dès qu'une start-up se
développe pour faire part à l'étranger
parce que la fiscalité mais est meilleur
et le conditions pour le développement
et meilleur donc on n'a pas trop à se
vanter créer des start-up si dès qu'ils
ont atteint un certain niveau il sent
bon alors on a parlé de françois
mitterrand tout à l'heure dans cette
émission vous aviez même citer certains
de ses bons mots on va l'écouter
françois mitterrand tient
lors de son dernier 14 juillet à
l'elysée en 1994 à bien la question du
chômage déjà à l'époque et puis déjà
l'idée que ça va mieux je crois que la
reprise est là et que le premier
ministre a raison de le dire et le
ministre d'économie
je crois aussi que la reprise de la
croissance n'entraînera pas comme on a
pu le croire dans le passé un véritable
effondrement du chômage alors qu'ils
étaient notion ne sont pas identifiés
des emplois sont créés et simplement la
résorption du chômage
le suivra pas automatiquement il faut
que ne faut pas vivre dans cette
illusion il faut donc inventer d'autres
formes dans mais déjà à l'époque c'est
très vrai il avait raison sur la
croissance parce que deux ans plus tard
il ya une formidable croissance qui a
bénéficié à lionel jospin premier
ministre monsieur juppé ne l'a pas vu et
a fait la dissolution monsieur chirac a
fait la dissolution mais la croissance a
profité de ce point qui à mon sens n'a
pas utilisé autant qu'il aurait pu ses
bénéfices mais c'est vrai que le lien
entre croissance et emploi a changé et
qu'aujourd'hui tout passe par la
formation en formation initiale la
formation permanente une des réformes
très importantes que je propose dans ce
livre c'est de former tous les chômeurs
à des métiers nous faut bien se rendre
compte que dans 15 ans au moins la
moitié des métiers qui existent
aujourd'hui auront disparu et donc c'est
très important de former les gens à de
nouveaux métiers très abouti à catane 1
2 milliard non seulement la moitié aura
disparu mais une autre moitié frappa rue
c'est pas seulement des métiers qui
disparaissent et d'autres qui
apparaissent dans votre livre passe 99
points très précis l'espérance d'une
mondialisation heureuse n'est plus
crédible
est ce que ça veut dire que la
mondialisation c'est forcément
malheureux non non non non l'espérance
béate d'une médiation qui par nature
sérieuse
mais ce n'est pas vrai parce que il ya
beaucoup de bénéfices très important en
particulier le fait que la classe
moyenne a augmenté le nombre de pauvres
a baissé mais les conséquences négatives
sont énormes et donc il faut pas revenir
sur la mondialisation faut la corriger
massivement parce que la fermeture des
frontières serait bien pire que la fois
parce qu'il n'entend hausse que les
partis certains partis politiques
sortent sans sa tante yvonne et bien sûr
mais sa cote est très malheureux aussi
bien sûr et la concentration des
richesses est une catastrophe lé là la
concentration des pouvoirs la
l'abolition de toute réalité de la
démocratie parce que quand le marché
domine ce qui est le cas et que la
démocratie le marché mondial la
démocratie et locales la démocratie
n'existe plus aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que la politique n'attire
plus les des tas de gens c'est que le
pouvoir politique a presque plus de
pouvoir sur vous parle également de
l'argent l'ennemi c'est toujours la
finance disons la finance est un outil
quand la finance est un outil c'est un
outil donc c'est positif mais quand
l'outil prend le pouvoir alors ça
devient un ennemi donc faux faux pour le
tir est un outil quantité d'outils c'est
génialement utile mois la loggia que je
développe la fondation nous vous disons
landes avait raison à l'époque à au
bourget quand il avait dit que l'ennemi
c'était la finance disons que l'ennemi
c'est la finance quand elle est au
pouvoir et que la finance est un
formidable outil de la démocratie quand
elle est au service de la démocratie
comment vous faites vous avec justement
votre fondation on en parlait tout à
l'heure pour aider ceux qui oeuvrent un
monde meilleur et qui ont besoin
d'argent
bah je suis pas comme beaucoup d'autres
communes toutes les grandes fondations
américaines
nous mettons l'argent au service de
l'intérêt des générations suivantes
l'environnement au service des
entrepreneurs par exemple ça devant des
programmes en france où on est des
gamins des quartiers à se former pour
créer des entreprises ça marche très
bien
c'est très utile on fait c'est un peu
partout à travers le monde je vous ai
dit je rentre de beyrouth où on a des
libanais et les communautés syriennes à
le faire c'est ça fonctionne très très
bien peu partout à travers le monde donc
l'argent peut être très utile s'il est
mis au service d'une cause et pas aux
services de lui-même les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
on a vu pendant que pour cette primaire
de droite ne se sont peu déplacés ou
très très peu en france qui parle le
mieux selon voix sept classes populaires
et moyennes
explique la d'espérance la
prolétarisation les dangers et qui
flatte les perspectives face aux menaces
tant que quelqu'un vous dit ce que dit
front national c'était mieux avant il
attire il faut réussir à montrer que ça
peut être mieux demain ou après demain
nous en parler dans un chapitre qui
s'appelle colère est ce que ça veut dire
que vous craignez une forme de révolte
une forme de révolution de ces classes
populaires et certains nous sommes au
bord de révolution elle aura lieu
peut-être dimanche prochain en italie
avec un référendum pour matteo renzi
contre mathurin d'ici le vote auriel si
vous avez peur de la sortie de l'euro et
au dollar
on se pose la question gravement pour
l'état libyen subit elle y va ce serait
le système qui exposerait exactement
chose que des on est on est pas assez
conscients de ce risque énorme c'est que
si le référendum se passe mal et si
ensuite l'italie gère mal la la remise
en état de son système bancaire leur
peau exposée non je pense qu'on a des
solutions il faudra que l'italie
nationalisme en trois minutes et demie
son système bancaire ce qui est faisable
ce qui est lourd mais ce qui est
faisable qu'on ferme un peu les yeux sur
les violations des traités européens
dans ce cas là et on peut s'en sortir
mais enfin attachez vos ceintures comme
les risques de crises sont aussi là
c'était quand vous parlez du système
bancaire espagnol système bancaire
italien pour tous premiers signes d'une
premiers signes d'une crise majeure qui
pourrait encore arriver à tout le monde
avec votre fondation vous allez bientôt
remettre des prix a déjà fait tourner
bien lisse pour un monde meilleur je
disais tout à l'heure vous avez des
exemples à nous donner nous remettons
des prix le 7 décembre tous les ans on
fait ça et cette année on est en effet
des prix à des gens formidables à des
jeunes qui travaillent par exemple au
japon à proximité de fukushima pour
remettre en état les des commis ce pays
dans les quartiers en france on met un
prix à de jeunes qui sont partis de rien
et qui ont créé une marque de mode
remarquable à des chaînes qui sont
également fin fond du sénégal
comment vous les dénicher vous allez
trouver comment allons nous avons des
équipes sur le terrain et grâce à nos
mécènes des grandes entreprises ou les
institutions internationales qui nous
aident rouler trouvera les aides
on est très fiers de faire ça je vous
dis moi je n'ai pas plus de grande joie
que d'aller les voir sur le terrain donc
pour avoir une vision positive de la
planète aujourd'hui malgré ce que vous
écrivez sur paulin oui parce qu'on est
vivement la peine de mort ça veut dire
que demain ça va être compliqué ça veut
dire que près demain peut être
magnifique si on a le courage de
regarder plus loin que ce bout de son
nez est en effet venez regarder
positif planète notre site donnez donnez
nous plus de moyens il est bien
distribué utilement comme tout le monde
a besoin d'argent de façon totalement
transparente et tous les dons sont
utilisés pour 15 euros on donne une
santé à une mutuelle de santé à une
famille de l'agasc harrouche sa vie ça
vaut la peine
voilà merci va on représente le la rive
jacques attali vivement après demain
chez fayard
merci d'avoir été avec nous je crie
merci beaucoup mais quelles qu'en soient
à tous et à la semaine prochaine